so funny enough that we're starting on a
timely manner in Time series forecasting
talk so before I begin I would like to
ask well first of all thank you for
being here and then ask the audience uh
who of you know what time series are
from the audience
great and who is currently working on
time series problems forecasting or
anomaly detection classification
great so more or less the half of it so
I hope during this talk during the next
30 minutes to tell you a story that
hopefully will entertain you and it's a
story about uh two mountains two big
mountains and a cliff between of them
and then it's a story about how we at
nixler are trying to cross that bridge
or build that bridge between those two
uh to those two those two different
families so I'm gonna start by
introducing the field what time series
are why they are useful then I'm gonna
talk a little bit about the first month
I know the first problem namely
classical methods in statistical
forecasting and then afterwards I'm
going to introduce the second one time
namely deep learning or newer machine
learning methods in in the field the
development of the story will be
presented at the very fourth point when
we try to cross and we attempt to bridge
those two different opposites and at the
end hopefully I'm gonna entertain you
with some more adventurous of the next
team
so what what why time series and why are
they important or useful
we do believe that the operational DNA
of the world is time series data so
financial data electric data iot data
it's old map and in tabular form and
most of it and most of the times it
comes as a data that is indexed across a
times or samples across different
regular intervals of times so the
applications are really huge but some of
the most classical ones are electricity
demand forecasting electricity price
forecasting trying to optimize Supply
chains by being able to forecast
millions of different items across
locations across categories but
obviously Healthcare data time series
data is also quite important in
healthcare
and recently we have seen an explosion
of a
use cases in Telemetry and observability
data so some some folks folks are using
mixed land time series technology to
detect anomalies for example to identify
a certain anomalies and past data and to
try to predict anomalies in future data
formerly speak ing the
the problem that we're trying to solve
is quite easy we're trying to to solve
this multivariate regression problem
where we are going to use a historical
data and exogenous variables so
basically what we're trying to do here
on the right side of the equation is to
forecast certain Horizons based entirely
on past observation so it's it's on the
one side is very simple on the other
side it's quite complicated in in terms
of the past is not always a good
predictor of the future something is
sometimes it isn't but nevertheless the
future as an uncertain outcome that it
is it's it's it's always good to be able
to reduce that uncertainty about the
future and that's more or less how we
understand our our task As Time series
practitioners so that's that's the
setting and now in the setting we have
two important players or two families or
two mountains as we as we introduced on
the one side we have a traditional
methods the field was developed mainly
by statisticians and mathematicians and
econometricians who applied and
developed these methods to forecast the
market the stock market who tried to use
it for like for example predicting
inflation and trying to take seasonality
away from from inflation and some very
interesting models arose from that
specific tradition you probably have
used them have heard of them arima naive
cards exponential smoothing but that
tradition is well and Alive people are
still developing classical statistical
methods most prominently the field is
Advanced by by certain people around the
Monash University namely Rob Hinman who
has permanently developed a lot of
libraries and solutions for Dr ecosystem
there has also there have been also
newer models like for example the
complex exponential smooth ring which
was published I think last year so the
field is well and alive but on the other
side
a deep learning and machine learning
also had an interesting development in
the time series field and some people
started developing neural networks
teaching neural networks and some
classical models are roads in that
particular tradition namely lstm and and
recently more Transformer based methods
one interesting part about the story is
that the boat families don't really like
each other that much they constantly
attack each other they constantly
criticize each other and if you take a
look and participate in social media
they do like Twitter a lot they do like
LinkedIn a lot and they are very
expressive about the failures of the
other ones so you have statisticians
claiming that the Deep learning is it's
just a hoax and it doesn't really work
for tabular data or for time series data
and you have deep learning practitioners
saying that statisticians are not really
leveraging the power of newer
Technologies and newer computation you
even have interesting change of mind
inside the same family so for example
their same title with the same authors
at different times propose different
things that's that's regular in the
field that happens in Time series field
and certain people have grown very
frustrated and made or are making very
funny comments about the difference
between for example computer vision and
LLP and the field in tabular data
but we came to talk about the Knicks
lovers and and that's how the talk was
announced so what is the next lovers and
probably the best answer is that the Nix
levers is our attempt to to contribute
to the time series field and hoping to
make a living out of it so it arose from
the from the Loft that we have for a
useful open source or open source
software and that's what we're doing at
nixlr
philosophy aside the next levels is a
collection of libraries that help time
series practitioners to achieve
different goals we're trying to do
really a fundamental program in the
sense that we are trying to solve
statistical methods we're offering those
I'm gonna talk about that particular
library in Amendment we're also trying
to do research in neural forecasting
method methods but we also have
classical ml forecasting we have a
hierarchical forecasting we have a
trying to develop we're trying to
develop automated pipelines for people
with less familiarity with data science
in general and more recently we have
been exploring the development and
application of transfer learning to the
time series field
so let's begin our story with the first
mountain and how we are trying to live
with with that tradition so
what we decided was to create stats
forecast and stats forecast is trying to
bridge another Gap namely the Gap that
existed between the r ecosystem with
what which was a very good uh developed
in in the time series field for
classical methods and the python
ecosystem so we developed what we think
is the fastest and most accurate
implementations of many classical
algorithms for example autorima and ETS
or from Rob but we also have included
newer methods like the complex
exponentials mooded by by Ivan and
recent and more newer models like the
mstl we haven't announced this we're
gonna announce it soon but now you can
plot You can predict a and train models
for multiple seasonalities inside of
stats forecast and we're about to
release this week also uh for newer
models of the Teta family which have
also been proven to be quite successful
in the M3 competitions
one one thing that we're trying to make
different to the other wonderful
libraries that are out there is that we
designed this having scalability in mind
from the very beginning so stats
forecast offers through the support of
you out of the box uh compatibility with
spark task and Ray so it's really very
easy to do forecasting at scale and
training hundreds and thousands of
millions or of series you can also do
anomaly detection you have probabilistic
forecasting we we are trying to copy one
of the projects that we admire the most
in terms of the API and the syntax
namely sklearn so I could learn and with
the dot fit dot predict methods and we
also have a wide variety of other models
for intermittent forecasting a whole
family of crosstalk models Adidas
and finally and this is very important
for us a very large battery of
benchmarking models or Baseline models
where you can really compare if your
attempts at doing or solving
specifically forecasting tasks are
really generating value or are below uh
classical historic average or seasonal
life which which which sounds maybe
ridiculous but for those of you who have
worked in retail sometimes seasonal
knife it's better than very
sophisticated models and and sometimes
we don't want to admit that but I think
and and we at the team do believe that
that sometimes simple is is better and
that's one of the motivations behind a
stats forecast here are some numbers but
basically what we want to show you is
that you can do a like a benchmark at
scale you can train 10 million of Series
in less than 43 minutes and spending
less than 20 dollars and you would have
a nice table with a a huge amount of of
bass lines to to beat so as a sparring
partner this this benchmarking at scale
service it's quite interesting you can
also include exogenous variables you can
include prediction intervals for certain
models and we have done certain
benchmarks you can reproduce them one of
the things that we really like is or try
doing is making every claim a backable
by empirical evidence so if you go to
the repositories and run the experiments
you should be able to reproduce this
probably you have to fix the the
versions because those libraries are
also evolving recently for example
profit did some updates on this faster
still like it's it's we think still has
said like some some work to catch up but
well as you can see it's it's faster and
more accurate than many prominent
libraries and this is because from the
very beginning we decided to tackle this
problem and trying to optimize it as
much as possible so most of the things
are compiled to combat just in time with
Zumba sorry which makes it very very
fast and it has this out of the box
implementations with different metrics
so after
developing this Library we wanted to
test it against one of the most famous
time series libraries out there profit
which was developed by a Facebook back
in the day and it's a very fancy library
and a lot of people are using it it has
more than I think 20 000 stars on GitHub
but if you actually run the numbers and
try to predict across a benchmark a set
of Benchmark data sets like M3 M4
tourism which are very classical data
sets in the time series field you would
realize that an arima a classical arima
developed in the 60s can be 70 percent
more accurate and almost 40 times faster
and this does matter because a lot of
Enterprises around the world are
trusting that the new hot technology
might be better than the old classical
tradition which is problematic because
for example for this experiment we paid
ten dollars in computational time in AWS
credits uh running the Autorama
experiments and we paid almost 300 using
the The Profit implementation so it's
it's not only worse in terms of accuracy
it's really orders of magnitude more
expensive which is costing is costing us
money and is is I'll time that when it's
time that shouldn't be used Computing so
here again what we are trying to to show
is that new is not always better and
that big names are not always better so
do do the job that is necessary and go
back to the basics and maybe start uh
with some with some classical benchmarks
um so in conclusion for from this first
side of the story we do think that
statistical models are a very good
Baseline we do think that sometimes
statistical models are all unique uh and
we do believe that stats forecast does
offer a robust alternative for
benchmarking at scale with proven models
we also believe that it's easy here you
can see how to train different models in
in less than 10 lines so basically you
just have to import the libraries select
the models that you want to use out of
the very large battery and you just pass
that list of models to the stats
forecast you define the data frame
Define the frequency and specify some
some settings in the in the
parallelization and with the forecast
method you can do forecasting at scale
in less than 10 lines with many
different models
so great but what about the the the
other side of the story so if there If
This Were A families probably our mother
would be the right side where where we
have the the strict pot carrying his
side of statistics and math and on the
right side is our Our Father who is
probably loving and more permissive in
the in the in the Deep learning side and
we want to bring them together we want
to bring those two families together so
what are we doing and why why uh care
about the right side and deep learning
if statistics is so great
well deep learning does indeed offer
benefits over statistical methods and
over classical machine learning methods
in so in in sometimes so three of the
main advantages of the deep learning
methods are that in some cases it does
improve accuracy significantly as we
will see particularly for for example
long Horizon problems it does make
pipelines simpler a lot simpler than
machine learning pipelines where you
have to care a lot about feature
engineering and feature creation and
it's very scalable one of the main
difference between statistical methods
and deep learning methods is that deep
learning don't fit local models you have
Global models that make the very or have
very nice very nice features also one of
the very exciting supplications of
exciting applications of deep learning
for time series is the possibility of
implementing transfer learning in the
field solving the zero shot problem so
imagine you have a you're a retailer and
you have a product that don't have
history because there are new products a
new line of genes a new line of of
whatever piece of clothing but you want
to somehow predict what's going to
happen classical models need always to
go back and see out the history with
deep learning you can do transfer
learning and solve that zero short
program for example that's a very
exciting thing and
and and regardless of what we think are
the main advantages of deep learning uh
empirical evidence in the last M
competitions has shown that deep
learning has a very good shot at being a
top performing in Time series so if you
look at the M4 and M5 competitions you
will see that some deep learning methods
have have really performed very very
well
and those methods and making those
methods available in a scalable and
user-friendly way is what we were trying
to do and are trying to do in the neural
forecasting package of the nixler
ecosystem and here the features are you
can also include exogenous variables you
can also have forecast interpretability
with certain families of models I'm
going to talk about that in a minute in
a minute
you get the probabilistic forecasting
you can do a different error metrics
automatic model selection we we made it
so that it's very easy for new users to
do auto rnns or Auto lstms where you can
like do hyper parameter optimization
over a space of different configurations
it has a simple interface it has this
exact same interface as the stats
forecast library and it has a wide
collection of deep learning models MLP
MLPs lstms
rnns a dilated RNN models from the end
beads and heats yes yes RNN and and a
lot of the former family models
um
so
that's that's the other side of the
story
but now how do we how do we Bridge it
how do we establish like a link between
those two big traditions
and and why do we need a link and and
the answer is that neural networks are
indeed powerful and flexible but they
are not always interpretable they are
very often hard to to understand and and
we do believe that under
interpretability it's it's important in
the in the field and that's why we uh
and that's how we started trying to
build this that bridge we we try to
follow the path of people that we admire
a lot namely Boris or asking and the
Joshua Avenger team who started
developing one of the first attempts to
solve that bridge between the two
mountains which is the end bits model
and the end bits model has performed
well in different competitions but it's
also quite interesting in the sense that
it aligns itself in the tradition of
signal decomposition so it's not only a
neural network model it also offers the
possibility to decompose the signal in
classical elements like strength and
seasonalities which are very important
to understand if you're trying to make
important decisions based on on the
forecast and what we were doing back
then as researchers is to expand the end
bits and to include exogenous variables
in the end with to make it even better
and we published a paper called envits x
x stands for exogenous variables and
indeed accuracy was improved
significantly but we realized that there
were some problems and and the problems
that we realized is when we started
doing long Horizon forecasting with
classical methods and with the end bits
we realized that it was very bad that
accuracy and complexity grew everyone on
accuracy decreased and complexity grew
so we started looking into this distant
future and tried to figure out a way to
solve the long Horizon problem
and and why is it a problem why why is
long Horizon a problem namely
a you have a very like poor trade-off
between bias and variants if you use
classical statistical methods you have
very high bias if you try going with
newer machine learning or deep learning
models you have more variants and in
both cases you suffer from a lot of
computational complexity and why because
there are two ways of approximating long
Horizon forecasting one of them is the
classical sequential predictions namely
you predict t plus one and then you use
t plus one to predict two plus two and
so on and and this is this is a very bad
idea if you have long Horizons because
it concatenates the errors right so if
if you start deviating a little bit and
you end up very far away from the signal
so classical alternative is to use
what's called multi-step predictions
where you try to forecast the whole
Horizon at once and and this is in terms
of accuracy better but it also it also
has certain problems namely that
performance does the performance in
terms of security Dot us it grow very
fast in relation to the Horizon as you
can see there in the graph on the left
and also on the graph on the right you
can see how the number of parameters
grows significantly and very fast in
relation to the Horizon so the problem
with the classical methods is that or
the even the Deep learning methods is
that they are not accurate they they are
highly complex and they are a highly or
very slow
so what's the solution and and we
started thinking and and came up with
this idea
that in principle is very simple namely
reduce the problem so let's go with a
multi-step approach but let's start
taking pieces of the middle so instead
of having the whole multi-step Horizon
let's take every second observation away
or every third one or every n amount of
observations and interpolate between
those two observations and that
intuition of interpolating between a
multi-step approach is what we tried to
develop in the end hits architecture
where we combine this multi-rate signal
sampling and hierarchical interpolation
with the techniques that we learned from
the end bits architecture so what we are
doing intuitively is we we fix the the
multi-step Horizon and then we have
different amount of of points the fewer
the points the higher the lower the
frequency and and the more points we
have the higher the frequency and what
the neural network work is doing here
with the what the end hits architecture
is doing is every stack is learning at
different frequency so at the beginning
the the distance between the points is
bigger and then we start learning the
different frequencies of the of the
signal and and some of you might
recognize a similar image from from from
your math classes where or your physics
classes and it does have indeed a
relation to to the Fourier transform and
we wanted to explore that idea so we
tried to to show and we we didn't and
you can read it in the paper we show how
the end hits can perfectly reconstruct
harmonic signals from synthetic data
demonstrating that indeed the end hits
and that intuition of doing a sampling
and then interpolating it does indeed
help the model specialize and learn
different frequencies and different
stacks
so now the the big question is should we
should we or can we apply this to real
world data is this extensible to to
actual data set so if it was and and to
motivate the idea it would be great
because we could take one signal and and
the end hits would do something very
similar to the classical models and it
would decompose the signal in familiar
elements like Trend seasonalities and
and that would be indeed a huge
advancement for for interpretability in
neural network methods so we went out
and tested this against many different
data sets a long Horizon data sets
electricity Transformer temperature
exchange rate electricity load even the
San Francisco Bay area highway traffic
and other data sets and
a a amazingly the the end hits did very
well it did perform good on real on real
data it showed that 25 improvement over
the best paper Award of a triple AI 2021
which is relevant in the field because
it was one of the first times that
Transformer based methods started
gaining popularity for time series so
it's it's in summary it's a lot more
accurate and Transformer based methods
and it's a lot less expensive it's 50
times faster or it takes 50 times less
computation
so here you can see the graphs but I
think the important question is why does
this matter and and it matters in in a
theoretical sense or at least we think
it does and this is some food for
thought for you but we we we think we
have shown that the end hits is indeed
an expansion or has an interesting
relation to the Fourier transform we
also showed that the end hits is a very
cool door to cool topics like wavelet
transforms and an information Theory a
la Shannon
and also for example that the end beats
the model that we introduced at the
beginning is just a special case of the
end hits where the the the length
between the points is very very small
on the Practical side and thus this
might be less less
this might be more more interesting it's
simply a better cheaper easier and
simpler than a lot of other models so so
go go and try it out and and and and we
think this is really exciting at least
for us this was mind-blowing when we
came to to this conclusion
but again uh this this part was maybe
more research related but go out and
test it you simply have to import the
libraries Define the models and call it
with a simple train fit uh
syntax and you can see how the end hits
performs in your particular data sets
that being said be wary the Deep
learning needs indeed more manual work
and then statistics sometimes that you
do need to to specify some good
parameters so go out test it and and
write us if you have any questions
and that's how we tried to bridge the
the Gap and and the Further Adventures
that we wanted to present and this is
the final section of the talk uh we are
further developed a forecasting
ecosystem where we're trying to do so we
have established certain hierarchical
forecasting methods where you can solve
for example the problem on how do I
reconcile forecasts at different levels
of hierarchies imagine you're a retailer
and you are forecasting products from
different categories across locations
from different like counties or states
or countries and you want to reconcile
them in a heart in a in a coherent way
you can use these methods to do so and
we're also working on a low latency
forecasting API for developers this is
intended for for people who don't do
Python and want to like include
forecasting into their web applications
with JavaScript react whatever whatever
language you can imagine
and uh that's it we would like you we
would like like to invite you to join
the communities we are uh happy to to
have more people join this this
adventure and and this this this project
if you want to tweet uh be welcome
Federico our fourth co-founder who
couldn't be here is going to be happy to
read about your your thoughts and
Twitter and as an open source project we
we would really like to thank the
different contributors that have helped
us do this project a reality
and uh that's it that's that's the talk
thank you
we have a few minutes for questions
great
sure okay um I just was curious like uh
for instance uh predicting
faults in like uh manufacturing flying
or in my case I'm actually thinking
about software development and build
quality we're able to forecast the
quality issues there
quality issues in terms of potential
bugs that might arise from a certain
like merge domain or or
other times we encounter things like
things like our
Services can overwhelm the amazing okay
good great
you have similar things in that country
yeah there there's a certain company
that is collecting a lot of different
locks on Telemetry and they want to
identify what certain Behavior it
becomes a typical to in order to
anticipate a possible failure or to
provision infrastructure and that's a
classical use of a probabilistic
forecasting how they are doing it is
they do the the forecasting intervals
and everything that is above or below a
certain level is considered an anomaly
so indeed it can be applied to those
specific fields that you mentioned
thank you
so
work a lot more with like medical time
series data and so I was wondering do
these packages kind of handle like
missingness because sometimes like if
they think are like lab values and those
are missing frequency isn't doesn't have
like a regular Cadence to it it's also
kind of like relatively sparse through
these packages already handle that kind
of like built in or is that something
that is like coming down the line or
yeah
two of my co-founders are here and I
know this this is a very like exciting
topic for kids so maybe can you want to
answer that question so first on on uh
maybe you can go and then I can go with
the frequency yeah so so these neural
models here uh they assume cool data
um
so yeah but uh we're working on on
problems with missing data or like when
the features are different uh like
because we know that we have experience
on software data sometimes uh I don't
know one of the sensors come out right
there so yeah and uh regarding changes
in frequency domain uh the end kits
basically is performing a wavelet
Transformer and it is able to
accommodate changes in the frequency of
the day so basically it's doing almost
like a Fourier Transformer localized and
in that regard is able to to tackle this
kind of uh like I would even say like
non-stationary data
but uh we answered two questions was
there another uh parsitness oh sparsity
and uh we are working on um
distributional methods that can
basically work as a plugin to to neural
methods basically you change a bit the
loss function and train for example for
sound regression or a poisson mixture on
top uh and such distributions are able
to fit uh sparse data but yeah so so
it's it's basically like a plugin and we
have them yeah
thank you sure
um have you built in or are you planning
to build in facilities for the
evaluation of to facilitate because you
know different ways of validation across
validation and so forth and time series
tends to be a little trickier than
another domains yeah that's that's a
very interesting question and the short
answer is yes one of the core methods of
the core class in both cases is a
cross-validation where you can do
different cross-validation strategies
with different like Windows and and and
step sizes and you can like do what some
people call back testing at scale so so
yeah
thank you
sure please
do any of the libraries of the ecosystem
support multi-seasonality at the moment
yeah the mstl in the classical methods
and the end hits in the in the neural
methods
thanks
[Music]
uh have you thought about incorporating
any of the like uh gasoline process
approaches to a Time series
transformation they kind of fit they
don't type in like the left or the right
um but yeah so we had like this very
cool idea during a glass summer about
extending the end Heats method which is
currently a point forecasting method
into probabilistic World basically by
using the closeness closeness on the
additivity of the version process
basically you can transform the entities
into a prolific method and and use the
fact that gaussian processing processes
production process and and have like a
long Horizon forecast include but yeah
it's also we we had the thought and then
it's a it's a immediate it will be
immediate right thank you
then I'm gonna take a picture
and if someone has more questions like
that they want to ask in in a like more
Private Matter or whatever we are going
to be here during the days and happy to
to help you and I write reiterate the
invitation to to join the community and
and to help us make make these libraries
better and to help and make the the
forecasting field better
thank you very much
[Applause]